smart people are not very smart actually
smart people in some of these colleges
are absolute idiots what do i mean well
there's a brand new tweet that is going
epically viral
nina strominger who is a professor said
i asked wharton students what they
thought the average american worker
makes per year and 25 of them thought it
was over six figures one of them thought
it was 800 000
really not sure what to make of this the
real number is 45 000
now of course there's a couple of ways
to look at this one they're just dumb
that's probably actually not right two
is they're misinformed they basically
don't have the information and therefore
there's making educated guesses which
aren't very educated or what's more
likely is that people who end up at
wharton one of the top financial schools
in the world
actually if you were to ask them what is
the average salary the average income of
the people you grew up around that
you're surrounded by that are your
family friends actually most of them
probably do have an average income of
six figures but ultimately that isn't
the right answer obviously the average
income is around 45 000 and so what this
proves is that we need to do a better
job not only a financial education but
also of making sure that people
understand whether you lived in a rich
area or a poor area whether you lived in
an urban area or a rural area not
everyone is exactly the same as you and
ultimately this is one of the reasons
why i think that part of the education
system one of the things we do a
horrible job of is we should actually
expose people to much more in terms of
different ideas different locations
different people and also different
cultures when you're looking at finance
or you're trying to understand investing
being able to understand what's going on
in other financial markets or with other
financial assets is really important
that diversity of experience that
diversity of thought ends up actually
being a superpower when you're trying to
be a better clearer more effective and
informed thinker but ultimately what
this shows is that we literally have in
the halls of some of our most elite
institutions
kids who are completely detached from
reality they think that the average
salary is six figures
and somebody thought that the average
salary in america was eight hundred
thousand dollars a year
i don't really know what else to think
about this other than this proves we got
a lot of work to do and not only is it
around financial education but it's also
just in teaching people how to be
critical thinkers how to be independent
thinkers and how to actually solve
problems without just saying stupid [ __ ]
like this what do you guys think about
that i mean whoever said eight hundred
thousand dollars is a legend like what
should be expelled 800 000 is the
average like what world are they living
in
that is uh absolutely wild i like
i mean take it for what it is that's
what they're saying i i feel like there
had to be some confusion or something
that just seems like an outrageous guess
like i don't know they're educated the
other thing that i'll say is 75 of them
did not think it was over six figures
so as much as it is easy to kind of dunk
on these kids
majority of them actually didn't think
that yeah right
but 25 is a very big number compared to
what you would think yeah and then of
course the one at 800 is just wild john
what do you think
i mean that's supposed to be a uh
wharton's a very good school right
traditionally it's known as a lot of um
people who are now in high power
situations and high influence in markets
and everything went to wharton so that's
pretty surprising um just not knowing
that but it's probably not their
specialty right there it's not their job
to know that it's interesting that
someone thought it was eight hundred
thousand dollars i mean that is
egregious i would call it there's a fool
in every crowd yeah and when you think
about it to be honest america is
obviously um a lot more prosperous the
people that live here than all around
the world so i think it's 85 if you
if you live on more than 30 a day you're
in the top 15 percent of the world
oh i bet you you're even more elite than
that no that's it if you're born in the
united states you're probably in the top
five percent globally almost four
billion people in the world so a little
bit more than half you can call it live
on less than six dollars and 70 cents a
day yeah that's wild yeah i i forget
what the stat is but it's like if you're
basically that's 20 that's less than
2500 bucks a year yeah if you live in
the united states you're in the top like
10
globally right and i think that it's
actually if you live in the united
states and you're above the poverty line
you're in top percent globally if you
are at warden and you think that the
average person makes eight hundred
thousand dollars a year you should get
kicked out of wharton that's like an
intelligence test that you failed you
sneaked your way in here somehow your
parents i don't know how you got in but
you failed you're out you're done
what are the odds that the person who
thinks that people get paid 800 000 a
year is also the person that their
parents paid for for them to get into
building that's a student yeah that kid
definitely has
their family name on a building at
wharton
kid doesn't even live in the dorms and
if you're in that kid's study group
leave immediately yeah kids like what do
you guys mean like when i go to the
country club like everyone at least
makes 800. like
you guys don't make a million poor yeah
oh you meant media
yeah like just and but he but here is
the other thing i think that's really
important right is that like there are
people who have that mentality as much
as we're joking around and stuff like
there are people who have that mentality
uh but i also think that it's really
important not because it's like oh kids
shouldn't be stupid but it's when you
actually get these people who uh have a
high probability of being successful
being in positions of power or influence
etc if they're actually operating with
the mentality that the average american
makes over six figures even if it's 800
whatever uh the decisions they make are
completely detached from reality right
so like let's just i don't know uh how
many politicians went to wharton but i'm
sure that there's a uh wharton is one of
maybe five six ten schools that there's
an outsized number right it's stanford
harvard mit wharton yale wherever
and when you think about that uh there
is likely to be
uh somebody from that school that's
there right now that ends up in a
position of power or influence either at
the state local or uh federal level and
so like they're making investment or not
investments they're making policy
decisions
based on this 25 percent of the people
like that's wild and it's easy to see
like that's where we get a screwed up
world is the people just they don't
understand like dude what like there's
no way and then the other thing too that
i think is really important is like the
the whole idea of like coastal elites
people on the west or east coast they
think everyone lives like them they
think everyone has the same viewpoints
as them and then you're like oh flyover
country and then you learn that like
people and you know i don't know uh some
of these states that are like i don't
know iowa right they're like dude what
are you guys talking about you guys live
in a shoe box in new york city pay these
outrageous rents have all these crazy
ass ideas like you know what i do i'm
happy right
i go to work every day i hang out with
my friends and family i go to the bar on
friday night my biggest problem is
finding their biggest problem is finding
the uh baseball game on cable yeah yeah
just like dude
there's like some weird rules out there
yeah you guys you
yeah you guys live like a miserable life
right but by the way then the people on
the east and west coast they think the
same thing of like the flyover country
of people in the south or whatever and
so it's like look everyone has a
different view of the world everyone
lives a different lifestyle some people
do it out of necessity because they have
to be somewhere for a job or family or
whatever
other people choose specific lifestyles
but i think that what we're watching
here is just like this is a perfect
example of how
getting exposure to a bunch of different
ideas a bunch of different cultures a
bunch of different people and also a
bunch of different uh markets really can
be a superpower it can give you an
advantage in life because there are
people who think that the average salary
in america is 800 thousand dollars and
they they literally could be your
colleague
like imagine if that's your colleague
and they're like yeah like you know i
think that we should go and uh of course
we're going to fly first class because
everyone makes 800 000 right it's crazy
stuff